for 11 years Emma and Lee Lovell built a
life in Australia but in just one night
that life was shattered as Intruders
enter their home late on boxing day Emma
was stabbed to death her husband injured
but survived now facing having to raise
their two daughters alone
[Music]
this world is devastated from her loss
sort of sensualism
I don't know
I don't know what people do it for
two 17 year old boys have been charged
with murder Tracked Down by police dogs
to a nearby site early on Tuesday
they're thought to have been already
known to authorities their alleged crime
sending Shivers through this quiet
suburban community North of Brisbane
it's where the levels settled after
moving from Ipswich where Emma's school
friend Christina is grieving her loss
she says Emma died trying to protect her
children
it's heartbreaking to think
that my best friend took her last breath
because somebody decided they needed
what was in their house they'd bought
this house for them to keep their
children in to keep their children safe
in
and just
took her last breath
and died
in what is such a heroic Act
trying to keep them keep her babies safe
that safety forever robbed from her
family who now have to find a way
forward without Emma
Sky News